mais pas le journal du art monsieur de
ok bienvenue sur le journal du art is
les are you ready for a
[Musique]
fantasy je n'ai pas besoin de me
présenter la présentation se fait par le
visuel I Love You la France je suis né
le 22 décembre 1976 un chiffre qui est
incroyable je crois énormément à la
numérologie la destinée le karma was a
good day
mon enfant s'est passé très différemment
des autres parce que je suis né en
feline c'était très compliqué ah non
j'ai jamais rien voulu faire c'est la
chanson qui a voulu me faire à l'époque
j'écrivais des chansons j'aiécris mon
premier texte pas celle que tu crois en
1996 qui été signé par Sony Music en
2002 fait pas
beaucoup
400000 c'est pas mal pour une petite
fille qui a écrit un texte à 17 ans oh
il av pas avait pas la réalité c'était
moi j'étais la T la réalité j'étais
avantgardiste on est venu me chercher
moi j'ai pas fait de casting je
travaillais avec Canal Plus avec
moustique sur grossse land sat voilà et
on m'a dit venez chez nous Ctait M6 à
l'époque et chant desmol venez chez nous
on vous promet que votre disque sortira
et votre livre voilà donc je voulais pas
le faire mais je l'ai fait parce que la
proposition et le contrat était correct
puis j'en avais un peu marre de laver
les assiettes et puis de VI dans une
chambre de bonne au 50e étage c'était
fatiguant euh Starak exactement parce
que Starak avait reçu la chanson
justement pas celle que tu croyais tu m
et euh moi j'étais tellement émoie à
l'époque je dis ok je vais faire la
starac je vais chanter en prime time pas
celle que tu crois on m'a dit non il
fallait chanter en fait le casting
c'était l'hyne à amour de d'edit Piaf et
tout le monde devait
respecter il fallait chanter une chanson
d Piaf j'aurais dit non non je veux
chanter par celle que tu crois ou alors
j'aimerais animer l'émission est
complètement folle celle-là
il fallait chanter edit Piaf au jour
d'aujourd'hui j'aurais chanté edit Piaf
quand il me prend dans ses bras il me
parle tout bas je vois la vie en rose il
me dit des mots d'amour j'aurais pu le
faire mais à l'époque j'étais dans un
critère à 18 ans urbain vous avez
commencé voilà j'aurais fait ça j'aurais
pu chanter ces chansons là love parce
que je peux vraiment identifi elle il me
fait un peu de la
rue ah bonre mais non j'aime j'aime
beaucoup F je la trouve fantastique
c'est franchement ma première ma
première inspiration le fait d'être la
rue de faire des spectacle comme ça
c'est un peu les fait CIRC Dieu Dieu est
ma première inspiration non en vérité
j'ai énormément de de Love et
d'inspiration pour James Brown je
l'adore et j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer grâce à
i love you so much mousse thank you
grâce à M j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer James Brown and L cvits je
nai jamais été victime d'aucune
discrimination j'ai toujours été adopté
et adoré par tout le monde par les plus
grands je vous dis si j'ai reçu un
rendez-vous d'alin du Greff et de Fabien
Bichet j'avais 18 ans je leur avais
envoyé tument tu me plonges dans le noir
jece j'avais envoyé une lettre de
motivation ça n'existe plus vous rendez
compte de en fait j'aimeris animer une
émission mais pas le journal du monsieur
de bienvenue sur le journal du
bon la météo j'ai fait casting ça
n'était pas bon parce que j'étais
j'étais trop forte pour la météo fa
bououp plus éteinte pour dire qu'il
pleut et cetera mais moi quand je dis
qu'il pleut c'est le soleil tu vois donc
ça n'allait pas du tout donc on m'a mis
avec ha et grosse avec moustique en 4
mois non c'était cool euh mais bon mais
après je devais faire de la fiction avec
Canal plus mais j'avais 18 ans mais
j'avais pas je parlais pas français
anglais j'avais pas cette Fame j'avais
pas le cursus mais Alain il avait déjà
senti vous imaginez d'avoir d'avoir
répondu à ma première lettre en fait
j'avais fait une première chanson qui
s'appelle tu men tu me plonge dans les
noir je travaille avec le mec qui boss
avec sola a Claude qui s'appelaitou qui
avait fait tous les titres pour les
dynasties
ça s'appelait slly SLO c'est un très
gros groupe et on trouvait que les s
était un groupe un nom plus anglophone
entreettemps comme avec Canal je faisais
que des extras j'étais embauché sur MCM
Africa et on a dit que les c'était plus
cool que affida et surtout même sur
Stara quand j'avais refusé ils avaient
trouvé DESY les voilà mais c'était pas
une histoire de racisme c'est parce que
j'étais très exotique et que il fallait
que ce soit un truc plus fantaisy
c'était pas du tout histoire de racisme
vraiment je pense que si quelqu'un
chantre dans une église ou
euh à mon Mar euh le public est roi et
je pense que quand tu as vraiment
l'esprit de l'art et que imaginons une
une fille comme
edit Piaf à l'époque qui chante et que
le public la découvre je suis sûr qu'il
y a un mec comme vous une meuf comme moi
ou un producteur qui dis wouh c'est
génial euh venez chanter avec moi à la
première de à Energie ou R pour ou sur
le plateau de Jordan par exemple j'ai un
message qui est fantastique donc déjà
n'écoutez jamais les esprits négatifs
n'écoutez pas votre voisin vos amis qui
vous disent ah bah non arrête de croire
que tu vas faire la couverture des
magazines arrête de croire que tu vas
faire un million sur Spotify arrête de
croire que tu vas habiter à Hollywood
arrête de croire que tu vas fêter ton
birthday avec Kud et Snoop Dog no crois
à ce que tu as dans ton cœur et si
vraiment tu as une une bonne énergie que
tu as un bon cœur que tu as fait des
belles choses et que tu bosses après
faut pas mentir c'est sûr que si tu te
réveilles comme je dirais pas le nom
comme un de mes assistant que j'adore je
dis dis donc tu es millionnaire toi
pourquoi tu travailles à 3h du matin moi
à 7h du matin je suis debout quoi merde
après pour les gens qui ont une vraie
passion un vrai sens d'humour beaucoup
de cœur je pense que la magie après
c'est dur parce que moi j'ai perdu
beaucoup de gens alors de parler encore
de la magie quand tu as perdu des
membres les plus importants de ta
famille ouais j'ai encore la fois malgré
ces difficultés mais je dirais qu'il
faut en aucun cas écoutz les autres moi
j'ai toujours écouté après c'est pas moi
je pense que j'ai plus écouté une voix
qui était qui était je pense que c'est
je pense qu'il y a des anges gardiens en
fait et je pense qu'on est tous on a
tous deux ou trois anges gardiens et des
vois quand tu te réveailles en disant
fais si fais ça fais pas ça t'inquiète
pas alors je vais pas vous mentir il y a
des jours où j'arrive pas à me lever je
vais pas mentir je vais pas faire la Myo
tu peux faire des show tu peux passer à
la télé tu peux faire de l'oseille tu
peux avoir un bel appartement tu peux
être AmiAmi tu peux être à New York il y
a des jours où tu dis [__] je suis
qu'une merde je me déteste la vie est
trop dure j'ai perdu mon mari mon ex ma
famille je vends ma maison je veux plus
à AER j'ai ma vie est un cauchemar oui
je va pas mentir je l'ai SP spécialement
dans après je suis une femme je devrais
pas dire ça c'est vrai que une femme
quand elle est en période de
menstruation ou ovulation moi ayant
énormément d'hormones je perds mes
qualités de de mec que j'ai un côté mec
et de Wire et là j'arrive pas à me lever
j'ai ma makeup artiste qui est là
pendant de 3 jours je suis une merde je
dis voilà je ne veux plus mais qu'est-ce
que je fais je veux plus aller en studio
je veux plus écrire jeux je mais
pourquoi faire tout ça et puis alors 3
qu jours après je rebois le café et là
je reviens la plus grosse [__] chez la
sorcière my money le show et le clip et
Machin et là j'ai [__] alléluia je
suis redevenu la petite orpheline je
suis redevenue affida mais il y a des
moments c'est très très compliqué je
vais pas mentir après effectivement on
devrait pas dire ça parce qu'à la télé
faut faire rêver les jeunes je vais pas
leur faire un coup de mytho il y a des
up and down il faut pas mentir je dirais
même que même pour des très très grandes
stars des stars incommensurbles qui
remplissent le stpple Center qui se sont
rendu compte à des moments où ils
étaient au bout de leur Life et très
misérable qui eux contrairement à moi je
ne dirai pas non font d'autres choses
parce que moi je fais rien je vais faire
2 heures de sport je vais boire deux
veres de vu Rico avec trois glaçons 10
cafés un fond de vin rouche comme je
fume pas je fais rien tu vois ce que je
veux dire il y a des après je pense que
c'est pour tout le monde après il y a
des gens qui vont pas le dire mais moi
je vérité parce que moi les gens me
connaissent pour ça pourquoi je vais
mentir en disant oua tous les jours
c'est la fête et tous les jours tu es
contente d'aller en studio et de de
passer à la TV est-ce que ça m'enlève la
peine dans mon cœur d'avoir pas papa pas
maman d'avoir perdu Reny d'avoir perdu
couot d'avoir perdu Los Angeles parce
que moi Los Angeles je veux plus
retourner je va pas envie de retourner
dans quelque chose quand je suis partie
à Los Angeles en fait ça me rappelle un
peu mon adolescence j'avais 24 ans j'ai
quitté m si c'est le loft on dit on va
pas parler j'avais un peu d'oseil je
suis parti au soficiel je jeis rest à tu
sais comment c'est west coast on va
rencontrer des on est cette génération
je l'ai fait je l'ai vécu merci bon Dieu
mais après tout ça c'est terminé en
drame avec la perte de Ronnie et de
couliot moi je veux plus rester à Los
Angeles pour avoir ses mémoires c'est
plus possible donc là je suis revenue un
peu à Paris je reste un peu à Miami un
peu à New York je ferai un peu plus
Allemagne la Suisse ou ma fan base et
puis à Paris j'ai quand même beaucoup
d'amis mais je vends ma maison et j'ai
donné tous mes meubles à la Croix Rouge
goodwill à Los Angeles parce que c'est
plus possible parce que tu t'assois chez
toi tu vois les affaires de ton mari là
où tu as dîner les moments que j'ai
passé avec couliio parce que couliio
était aussi amis avec Rony les
Américains c'est différent mais je veux
plus voir ça je vais devenir
complètement malade parce que ça
représente t temps tu imagines cou 2003
Rony 2005 c'est en fait c'est toute une
jeunesse voilà et donc ça c'est trop dur
c'est tellement dur et après il faut
continuer donc c'est pour ça je ne vais
pas mentir est-ce qu'il y a des jours où
ça va pas bah oui il y a des jours où tu
peux pas te lever à part ça avant crouo
ironie che j'étais très très contente
très heureuse mais vraiment il y avait
le théâtre il y avait Etien il y avait
les clubs il y avait que des belles
choses Reny était content du théâtre
couo les Américains sont très impresses
avec le théâtre parce que c'est en
général plus pour les gens de High
Society plus les Européens on a très peu
de méthist ou de renois en théâtre donc
pour eux en tant que américain [__] tu
es avec un casque tu es avec des blondes
et tout tu es tous les soirs tu remplis
tu même eux qui font de la musique le
théâtre a quand même un côté très classe
très noble et couou ironie était
tellement fierère que jeis au théâtre
d'avoir perdu ces ces deux membres de ma
famille dirais-je c'est c'est très très
dur je vais pas mentir je pense que
quelqu'un d'autre se serait mis une
balle dans la tête c'est tellement
compliqué alors il faut savoir que quand
je sors à l'extérieur n'habitant pas
Paris mais étant à Paris actuellement je
ne sors pas en affilat tneur je suis pas
folle quand même donc j'ai des cheveux
attachés j'ai petit foulard qui sur un
petit foulard rose ben un long t-shirt
basket je va sport et le masque donc les
gens quelque fois les gens me
reconnaissent à mon regard agressive de
garce ou le sourcil décoloré c'est FIDA
j'aimis pas du tout Ys whatever donc je
sors comme ça donc personne ne voit
quand je suis accompagnée de ma
maquilleuse de Yan qui est à la maison
le grand
blond mes assistants whatever je sors un
affidat tonner c'est c'est pas
prétentieux c'est pas prétentieux c'est
la réalité c'est tellement d'amour
c'est tu as les chauffeurs de taxi qui
te mettent leurs femmes qui disent
[__] je t'aime tu es mon inspiration
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est les femmes complètement
intello mais rebelles alors là bravo
vraiment vous de représenter après il y
a d'autres personnes qui me disent ça me
touche beaucoup vous avez beaucoup
souffert on vous suit depuis 23 ans
bravo donc ça c'est un peu attendrissant
et
presque ben j'ai presque les larmes et
après tu as les petites Gabin
complètement Rebell rockin roll très
bourgeoise qui connaissent cette chaînes
qui pensent que c'est ma chanson mais
moi je peux pas mentir ben je leur dis
en fait non je suis désolée pour une
fois c'est pas moi qui l'ai écrit c'est
la grande gpti par exemple et qui font
toutes les chorégraphies après tu as tu
as aussi une énorme community gé qui dis
tu m'as vraiment aidé à à à me battre
parce que comme comme toi j'ai j'ai
souffert de d'indifférence mes parents
m'ont mis dehors je me suis fait bouler
comme on dit aux États-Unis regarde ce
que tu as fait pour une fille qui avait
pas de père pas de mère donc
c'est c'est beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de
compassion beaucoup de respect par parce
que je pense qu'en fait euh pas parce
que je suis la plus belle pas parce que
je suis la meilleure parce que je suis
sincère et qu'en fait je suis une fille
comme du peuple qui qui qui s'est faite
vraiment d'elle-même donc c'est comme le
mec qui ouvre une pizza ou un kebab ou
ou euh en fait c'est quand tu viens
vraiment du bas en plus sans papa sans
maman et d'avoir acheminé ce chemin et
et puis je vais pas mentir je m'appelle
quand même Turner j'étais blesse par
Reny Turner et puis donc ça aussi ça m'a
donné euh je vais pas mentir une sphère
incroyable d'êt parti aux États-Unis de
m'appeler Turner et et et d'avoir ce
changement de vie de Dieu et de mon mari
peut-être parce que je l'ai méritaé
parce que je souffre beaucoup jusqu'à
présent je souffre beaucoup ma vie est
très très difficile les gens imaginent
quand il me voit F turnner à la télé ou
dans un clip ils savent pas ce que c'est
que le quotidien d' F turnner mais c'est
moi je suis un indépendant je suis
auteur compositeur productrice
euh j'ai ma propre boîte heureusement je
suis blesse j'ai une super makeup
artiste j'ai un monsieur que vous avez
vu qui me coiffe j'ai une team
magnifique j'ai des gens très humains
qui m'entourent mais tout ça je l'ai
fait moi-même à l'époque à 24 ans
j'étais signé avec epis Sonic avec Epic
Sonic en demmol M6 là aujourd
aujourd'hui j'ai ma propre compagnie
donc je fais ça toute seule donc quand
je sors à l'extérieur c'est l'extase et
voilà je reçois énormément énormément
d'amour je refuse jamais de photos ni de
FaceTime parfois c'est vrai que quand tu
es au présinique au Monoprix en train
tacheter des médicaments on des enax
tuas un foulard sur la tête et là c'est
vrai que je dis écoutez madame non mon
mari est décédé j'ai pas envie de faire
de photos aujourd'hui ça m'est arrivé
c'est rare mais je suis la seule quand
je suis bookqué à Marseille moi je
chante je suis payé pour trois chansons
quand c'est plein j'en fais trois plus
et ouais parce que les gamins ils ont
payé 150 balles ils viennent de Nice de
Bordeaux de Paris ils ont pris leur
chambre d'hôtel ils veulent leurs photos
moi en aucun cas je peux faire quatre
chansons ma fille tu as plus 20 ans tu
as 40 7 ans et tu es là il est 6h du
matin bah ouais mais moi je le fais
après c'est mon éthique c'est moi et
ceci peut-être explique mon succès sans
maison de disque sans radio tu imagines
ettienne un million de téléchargement
sans aucune radio sans aucun clip ah oui
C8 a passé le clip j'étais déjà à 800000
ou un truc comme ça C8 quand je leur
envoyé clip il l'ont passé dans le dos
je souffle la
M
[Musique]
non vous imaginez 1 million de
téléchargement sans radio et puis on a
performé au théâtre en club 1 million
sur Spotify sans radio sans promo tu
imagines que les maisons 10 payent
presque 1 million nous on fait 7000
personnes en show sans radio sans promo
juste parce que les gens me connaissent
depuis 2002 est-ce que c'est à cause de
ma désinvolture i mais en tout cas le
public a fait de moi en tout cas sur ce
titre numéro et je pense que à
Energie le succès sera planétaire je
suis vachement là-dedans je suis sûr que
a energy va être Paris
London Germanie Amsterdam Hollande
Autriche Japon là so la f c'est ce que
je
[Musique]
pense alors les projets là continu cha
là je fais le clip de high energy le
clip que je produis je réalise Brahim
ZBA hi Darling va m'aider aussi va
m'amener les danseurs le film à partir
du 13 octobre des dates et puis plein de
belles choses on on reste dans la
continuité de la continuation l'ambition
d'affid turn tout simplement mais malgré
tout j'ai un public qui est incroyable
j'ai la chance d'être là on va pas se
plaindre même s'il y a des mauvais
moment il y a quand même des très bons
moments là j'étais à Marseille j'ai fait
un show magnifique dans un château donc
voilà donc à energy
everywhere dans dans votre télé à la
radio et puis là il y a le film qui
arrive le théâtre revient je ne peux pas
donner plus d'information et le public
est roi ça c'est une histoire d'amour
thank you so much